Since our last update, we’ve made great
progress in the Regeneration areas.
At the end of November, the much anticipated
Kaiapoi Dog Park opened its gates to the public.
The ribbon was cut by Mayor Dan Gordon and
former resident Barbara Townsend, who lived
on the land where the park is located.
Dozens of four-legged locals joined the celebration,
with prizes awarded to Mr Kaiapoi, Miss Kaiapoi,
best dressed, scruffiest and waggiest tail.
Following a short delay due to the lockdown,
the roading in the surrounding area
has now been upgraded.
Charles Street now incorporates
what used to be Jollie Street.
It has been resurfaced, and includes a
new footpath and parking.
Over at Norman Kirk Park, the Cass Street
car park is also quickly taking shape.
During the last couple of months, the grass for the sports grounds has established well.
Irrigation has been installed and work on
the softball diamonds is now underway.
Construction is also about to start on the
changing rooms and public toilets.
They are due to be complete in October
and all going well,
we’ll see the sports fields in use
over the coming summer.
On the Kaiapoi River, a second round
of dredging is underway.
After removing the remaining high points by the
Williams Street Bridge, the barge will
move downriver to deal with silt build up
and further improve navigability for vessels.
The walkway between the
Williams Street Bridge and Trousellot park
is also receiving final repairs.
Once complete, the popular
“teeming” sculpture will return
following its removal after the earthquakes.